foreign
[Music]
I'm working as a scientist in the tumor
biology group at the German collection
of cell cultures and microorganisms in
Germany in short it is called the DSM
set and we are actually one of the
Europe's largest cell line repository
and we not only keep the cell lines that
are submitted to us but also we develop
cell Lines by itself and we try to
actually also do the quality assurance
and we offer sales and services for
different kinds of cell lines
uh if you have any questions during my
presentation or if you want to connect
with me if you anyways have any other
questions regarding cell lens
development process about DSM set you
can contact me on semi biotech gmail.com
the email address is in the first slide
of this presentation
but what I will be talking to you about
today is about optimizing the cell lines
development process and that would be
especially in the context of
bioprocessing and in by processing it
will be in the Upstream whatever
processing so to develop the cell line
by itself and then of course we would go
to the upscale and then from there
onwards how to develop them into the
industry
so with that I would like to start the
presentation
um
the first thing that I want to talk
about is that why would we need a cell
line for bioprocessing and that comes
with the term biologics our
biopharmaceuticals mostly
and the term biologics are
biophormastericals are almost similar to
each other it only refers to a really
broader range of products especially the
medicinal products all of them actually
share some kind of common features
now we know that in the traditional
medicines we synthesize compounds are we
synthesized medicines in the laboratory
and mostly adults kind of a chemical
synthesis of the compounds for synthetic
chemistry is involved there but in terms
of biologics the the bio products are in
in short the product itself is
synthesized in a living cell
that is why it is called the biologic
thing
and in the Pharma industry currency a
lot of drugs are being produced
um which would be termed biologics if I
give you a short example that would be
from for example the 2014 to 2018 so in
the these four years only about 68
monoclonal antibodies 23 hormones 16
clotting factors nine enzymes and seven
vaccines have been produced using a
biological system which means that they
have used cell lines to develop such
kind of products and these have been
already approved are in the process of
approval right now
so before going further into the process
of uh how these cell lines are developed
I would like to uh mention here that
what kind of systems can be used for
this process so the objective here is
that to produce a recombinant protein
are for example a monoclonal antibody or
any other kind of biological material
now we can use different kind of systems
and most of these systems are called the
expression systems because these
proteins would be expressed in these
systems so for example bacteria in that
I have given example here of E coli is
one of the most common examples of a
bacteria which is used for production of
different kind of material
the similar way yeast can also be used
and in that case we have saccharomyces
one of the examples insect cells such as
sf21
this can also be used and
my focus here would be on mammalian
cells and here the best example is
choices are the choices which are the
Chinese hamstring ovary cell line
most of these cell lines are most of
these biological systems that we use so
we have to select them based on our
product as cells based on what we
actually want to produce at the end so
one example would be that if you want to
produce for example the viral particles
so for that the best system here would
be the insect cells the sf21 sets for
example
the mammalian cells are the choices
these are actually selected if you want
to produce certain kind of vaccines
monophonal antibodies recombinant
proteins are hormones as well for
example so for such kind of system then
we would use mostly the mammalian cell
line
now to give you some insights into the
mammalian cell culture and how they are
used and why they are used for
biological biologic production
so mostly as I said before as well they
are used for the vaccines antibodies are
recombinant proteins production but why
exactly are they used as because of the
biological system itself as these
recombinant proteins would mostly be
used by mm mammal itself for example a
human being
these proteins would probably not need
any further modification and that we can
ensure if we use a system which would
also ensure that post translation
modification which is a necessary part
of these proteins production are
proteins Manufacturing in other words
protein folding as well as one of the
step which is required for the protein
production because usually we have the
amino acid sequence which is produced by
a gene so that that would be folded into
a protein as well and further the 3D
structure of this protein would be made
within the cell
so that is why we would use the
membership culture for that so we can
actually use such kind of biologically
available uh phenomenon and use this
phenomenon to produce our protein in
question
now this is actually the Upstream
process as I said before as well and it
will have a different kind of steps
involved in it so the most important
here is that we will transfect our Gene
of Interest which would encode for a
specific protein into the host cell and
for that we can use different kind of
vectors for example our classmates and
then afterwards we would select the
Clones of cell lines which would have
for example High productivity a high
proliferation rate uh even in terms of
the cell itself it should be having the
characteristic of the cell that was
actually
what we we begin with and then after
that we will subsequently go for the
scale up process and
the scalar process is that once we are
producing them in a small battery plate
or in a 96 oil plate or 24 website and
afterwards we would go to the flask and
ultimately we will go to the bioreactors
and in each step we should be ensuring
the quality of these clones of cell
lines as well
so the different types of these
mammalian cell cultures which are used I
have tried to come put here some of them
so depending on the purpose as I said
before we would use specific cell types
for example if we want to produce
proteins our antibodies or vaccines even
complex Therapeutics so for that we
would mostly use the Cho cell line at
the bhk heck 293
ns0 even the insect says
if you want to produce viruses for gene
therapy for example then as I said
before mostly we would use the insect
cell lines and this in in this case is
actually the virus and line we can also
use heck 293 cells which are one of the
most powerful cell line available
which can be used for different kind of
purposes we can also use c61 cells and
then finally if we want to go for the
cell type here regenerative medicine or
even personalized medicine
so for their purpose we mostly use
pluripotent stem cells and these are
mostly embryonic stem cells are adult
stem cells
so this would be then differentiated
into specific cell types for example and
those cell types will be then given for
cell therapy or regenerative medicine
these are only the examples and there
are many of other cell lines available
mostly these cell lines would be still
modified in terms of expression of
specific Gene and then afterwards we
would be actually giving them or using
them actually for our purpose in
question
so the process of a cell line
development that would be for us the
initiation of the biological biologic
production is I have summarized them
into five steps and these five steps are
for example the transaction once we
transfected the cells then we would
select the cells which are really
transacted which do have our Gene in
question
as the Genome of Interest so that would
be actually a pool of cell lines uh put
up cells of that particular cell line
and that would be then we would submit
them for pool selection so we would
provide some kind of pressure to these
pool of cells and then we would select
the cells which do have our Gene of
Interest
so once this boot is selected it's still
a pool so we do not know that how many
copy numbers are available in these
cells and in which says how many how
much copies are available
so that is why we will then go for the
Single Cell isolation or single cell
selection
and once we have isolated the single
cells we would produce the colonies of
these single cells and then we would
assess each colony for different kind of
quality parameters
so once we have isolated the the single
cell and produced a quantity of that
single cell which is
for our purpose in question is working
the best way that we will expand that
particular cell clone and then
characterize it as well and
characterization of course is dependent
on different kind of vectors so once we
have that thing as well the final step
would be the optimization process so
optimization would be not only for the
cell line as well but also for the
biologic production part as well and
once we have optimized this process we
will scale it up
now one thing that I would like to
actually mention here is the cell
banking part and my advice to you is
that
banking should be done at each and every
step so once we have transacted I said
we have a pool of cells available so the
ideal way is to actually pull this pool
should be stored in some way mostly
these are stored in minus 80
refrigerator are the deep freezer and
then if we have clones available so
those clones also should be stored in
the same way after characterization
after optimization at each step it is
better to bank the cells somehow and
either for example minus 80 the fridge
are also in liquid nitrogen why is it uh
so much important is that if you do that
if we have any problem in the future
steps for example if we do set banking
in Step number two
but we have some problem in Step number
four we have some contamination for
example so in that case we can again go
to step number two check out our the
cells from our cell bank and then
continue from Step number two and go
forward to three four and five but if
you do not have those tips available in
our cell Bank of course we should be
going back to the transfection part and
that again is a lot of Labor a lot of
cost and a lot of um time which we would
be needing for the whole process
so I will be presenting each and every
step here
how we do it at the smz are how we do it
in general
um for the cell line development and how
I have done it so far so the first step
here is the transfection part and
transfection is a really straightforward
thing we have a vector so in this case I
am giving you example of a plasmid
now the plasmid has some certain
restriction sites it has other parts as
well but it has some restriction size we
would be taking any consideration that
these restriction size should be
matching our registration sites in our
Gene of Interest
so the flanking region of this Gene of
Interest should have some distraction
sites which would be matching the same
size as the transmit so when we apply
some restriction enzymes to these
plasmids it will cut the plasmid at
those sites and once those are cut it
will be Hollow and then we would like it
our Gene of Interest using like as this
and then we would be having our plasmid
containing our Gene of Interest
now such kind of classmate would be
really available for our purpose that
would be the cell line development for
the specific kind of gene or protein
so how exactly it is done in the lab or
how we do it in the lab is that we have
such a specific transfection reagent
different companies are providing
different kind of transfection reagents
we mostly do it with the perfect timing
for example and this slip of your time
in reagent transfection reagent is
first of all suspended in serum free
media
then we have our nucleic assets which
would be DNA file sample cut it with a
certain specific restrictions enzymes
now we would make them up incubate them
for a certain time and then add them to
the cells the whole mixture itself and
incubate the cells with the transfection
reagent containing our nucleic acid now
the important thing here to consider is
the confluency of the cells of course
the cell line itself which you are using
should be selected based on your purpose
but the Confluence is also important the
best way is to actually add these
transfection reagent containing our
nucleic acid when the cells are 70 to 80
confluent in most cases if it is 80
complement it is better because we are
adding the incubating the cells with
these reagents for about two to three
days
which means that the test would go the
normal proliferation as well that is why
certain space should be available for
our cells to grow and that is why we
actually keep the confluency at 80
percent
the lower confluency should also be
avoided because in that case we will
have a lot of surface area available for
the transaction reagent but no cells
would be available on the plate so that
is why we will go for the 80 percent
confluency in normal cases
the second step in the cell line
development process is the pool
selection now you have other details
circuit the cells you have a pool of
cells some of them should have one
plasma some of them should have three or
four classmates and some of them should
have no plasmas at all so now to select
the cell which actually has the plasma
in question we use different kind of
essays a different kind of strategies
and this for example I will give you
example of antibiotic resistance are
fluorescence related change so normally
in the plasmid we will have an
antibiotic resistance chain for example
for mpcline streptomycin a Gentamicin we
can also incorporate the fluorescence
Gene for example the RFP or the gfp it
should be either red or green in color
to the plasma itself when we are
incorporating our
of course assessments can come with the
specific fluorescent stream with a
specific antibiotic resistance stream
now when we have our pool of sets we
would grow them for the antibiotic
resistance in the media which will have
that antibiotic infections so now when
the food of the cells which do not have
the plasmid inside them they would die
in that media because obviously they are
not antibiotic resistant but the pool of
the cells which help the transmit inside
them they would grow on these media
the same way for the RFP and gfp we can
use microscopy we can also use x sorting
of the cells
then again once we have the selected
pool we would isolate the single cells
and for the single cells we are using
different kind of strategies these
different kind of strategies can be
for example
that we can use the manual picking of
the single cells using a microscope so
with a spatula we can also sort the
cells by using fax machine and we can
use automated single cell isolation
machines as well which are nowadays
available and are given by different
kinds of companies
this is one of the most important part
of the cell line development because you
want to select a clone which actually
would be the most beneficial for your
purpose
so that is why a lot of care should be
taken at this time
for the manual selection as I said
before you have a microscope and under
the microscope you are manually picking
up the cells so this I have done for
example and during my PhD time in 2015
but nowadays different other methods are
available so I'm using those uh in my
research currently so the manual
selection of course that should be done
under the laminar airflow hood and as it
is shown here you have the cells under
the microscope and the laminar airflow
hood and then what you do is you scrap
the cells but before that you suspend
the cells and really high volume of
media and then actually mix them plate
them in a piece replace
so you have a lot of services area
available for the cells
so for example it should be 10 or 15
Confluence so you can actually pick up
single sales there and that is usually
done with a pipet chip using a fire pit
and you you just directly scrape the
cell a little bit and then afterwards
pick it up using the pipet and once you
have that you transfer it to the 96 web
LED put the corresponding media on top
of it and then let it incubate so it can
pull your face
so care should be taken here because
that is manual process that you are
actually picking up on these single
cells
the second way to do this single cell
isolation is by back starting and again
it is effects as a normal machine which
has a copet and some nozzle as well and
with a droplet you actually are taking
out only single cells through the nozzle
and this each Drop That should be
containing only a single cell and that
single cell then is directly poured down
and the 96 will set once you have that
then you go on and add some media on top
of it and integrate the cells again
now currently available the most
advanced method actually is the
automated single selection and here I'm
giving you one example from one company
where they are using this automated
machine to pick out a single cells it is
actually
uh having dual system and the Dual
system actually is that first of all it
is using kind of like effect sorting but
in effect sorting we are giving a lot of
pressure to the cells here in this case
they are not putting this much pressure
on the cell so basically it is kind of
like
um the droplet method and the pressure
upside is only through squeezing the
cells in a droplet so no pressure is
supplied on the cell and that's why you
will have a lot of high viable cells
so then again it is using and ensuring
the quality of the Single Cell isolation
process as well
so it is using the microscopic methods
and that is that one uh of the camera is
actually on the nozzle itself and one of
the camera is directed on The Well of 96
will split so it ensures first of all
that a single cell is actually getting
out of the nozzle and then it ensures
again in the plate that there is only
single cell which is poured down in the
96 percent
now I'm talking about this automated
machine because usually with the picking
up manually the single cells you are
applying a lot of pressure
and that pressure cannot be good for the
seller as well because it is stress it
has mechanical pressure
so you normally have less viable sets as
you can actually alter the cell
properties as well the same way is with
effects charging it is again a lot of
pressure and if the automated single
cell isolation then such kind of
pressures are avoided
fast is avoided level is avoided and
time taken for single cell isolation is
also really low if I give you one
example when I was using the manual
single cell isolation I actually ended
up
they're taking days for uh picking up
colonies but in case of automated it can
actually take a few hours
so
at the end you have single cells you
play them in 96. you put proper media on
top of it and then let it grow and at
the end you have Colony now those
colonies are then screened for the high
producers which will produce the high
amount of your protein in question and
then that high producer can be tested
using different methods for example
packs are Elisa if you want to test for
antibodies if you are producing
antibodies
then the next step in this process is
the expansion and characterization which
usually is done by livestream Imaging to
test the flow depression which cells are
proliferating faster which are slower as
compared to the original cell line then
you do SDR profiling using PCR to
confirm that it is the same cell type
you also do micro plasma testing for
possible contamination you check for the
surface the surface markers as well to
further ensure the cell type
and then you expand them in large
outlets and plus you biobank them and
then you actually test them for high
producers as well
now the media selection process as I
said before it should be the serum free
media and the cf3 media is essential
because
um usually in the serum it is best to
best variation between each serum which
we get there's a possible chance of
contamination within the serum itself
and usually the cellular growth and
physiological responses of the cells is
inconsistent in different kind of serum
and not to forget here is also that
certain compounds are sequestered in the
serum it says
the different kind of Alternatives
available for the FPS media and those
are those can be for example the serum
free media so in general they do not
only have Serum at the zero is free
media so it is not taken from the animal
um Source uh animal component free media
even protein free media and finally the
chemically defined method I prefer the
chemically defined one because in that
case you know exactly that what is
inside your media and how to further
identify that okay what kind of points I
should be taking in concentration before
I go for the production of specific
biology
then the final step is actually the
scale up or the optimization of our cell
line that we have produced and that we
can go back to our
initial state which is that we have
produced for example our cell line in 96
website then we transfer them to 48 will
play it 24 will play it and finally to
the small class which is 25 meter square
and it takes like five to seven uh
milliliter of media then we go to larger
flask and even larger and even larger
and in each passage and in each flask
that we are testing we are expanding
ourselves in we are checking for the
proliferation of the cell we are
checking for the viability of the cells
we are checking for the cellular
properties itself and finally we are
checking for
and how much of our biologic equation is
produced at each step so that actually
ensures that whatever clone we have
picked up in the beginning it is the
Clone which has the potential to go to
the industry to the bioreactors and to
produce our biological question and that
is especially important then because you
are not going on with only a single
clone but you actually pick up five to
six or seven clones which are the most
promising plots so at the end if there
is anything happening which would happen
in most of the cases anyways then you
have the Clone uh the opportunity to
actually pick up another phone which
would be the best one
so to finally sum it up what I talked to
you about is that the mammalian cell
culture is a robust and uh an accurate
method to produce your biologics and the
cell line uh selection process is
dependent on the product itself of
course
and some of the steps in cell line
development can be automated as I said
for example in case of um the the
automated single cell isolation method
and in that case you actually reduce the
time consumed during the process and
also reduce the cost
TWC media I showed you that it is one of
the most
promising methods to actually produce
your biologic Senate and that is in any
way the best choice for Salon
development as well because you should
be checking in concentration that the
the ethical reasons for the FPS use as
well
FPS is anyways produced in uh from the
fetal cult theorem which are actually
the live animals and third trimester of
pregnancy so yeah ethically it is not a
good idea to use the FPS in such a large
amount
and finally I showed I talked to you
about the cell banking as well that it
is a good idea to bank yourself at each
step because that way you will not only
reduce your cost but also the labor it
was and this whole process of selling
development
and with that I would like to thank you
for uh listening to my talk and if you
have any questions as I said before as
well you can contact me directly on my
email address at sammybiotech gmail.com
if you want to network if you want to
get more information about the cell line
development are about DSM says you are
free to contact me and with that thank
you so much and I'm looking forward to
the questions
um in the chat box